[Music]
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
with all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here we
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you i'm not gonna
make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
yet
[Music]
down in front of the bank automatic
weapons being fired
[Music]
you in the driver cannot drive
bank robbery suspects have taken an
ambulance
i got a cop shot gotta get him to the
hospital we're doing hostages now
i came to you for a loan you're my
brother have i ever gotten you anything
i couldn't get you out of lock
everything down
we're just trying to get home
we don't get to walk off into the sunset
[Music]
just chill out
gotta chill out hit me up
what's going on in there
these guys are nut jobs right here it is
[Music]
does your wife know you're up eggs
i'm sorry brother i think it's the best
of me
sorry that brought you into this
i just wanted things to be the way they
used to be we are trying to save you
[Music]
i'm gonna get you back home now brother
[Music]
and get everybody home
only in theaters april 8th
good night good night
yes yes yes good
[Music]
there are a night of other villains in
the world
but i am going to be
a super villain
[Music]
i am pretty despicable
all right all right i'm not minnie
please stop calling me that
time to strike
[Music]
my minions will save me
you like picking on little guys huh i am
a master of kung fu
uh
smoochie
i will teach you
here
ah kevin kevin kevin
[Music]
[Music]
why don't we make this a fair fight
okay
[Music]
you only get one shot
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something
we've got to breach in the perimeter
thank you
[Music]
how's light your mission long
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet our first test flight is a
go
let's get everyone home good luck
captain we're all counting on you
roger that
[Music]
fighting in the sky hello buzz i am
socks your personal companion robot
we're being pursued by a
just a massive robot
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
right here
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no wait noise is
fine very well good night sox good night
buzz
mrs kimura i'm here to offer you federal
protection
i know you're afraid but you can save me
right
i can help you stay alive
congratulations
you've just been erased
we've got the fbi with me we'll take
khmer in ourselves i can't let you do
that
there's been a breach you know the drill
i know what must be done
let's go grab her
game time
the mason pollard i know would never do
this something very serious must have
happened
bring him in alive
come on we gotta go
read up
the follower blocked mini commune's face
her biometrics and his own from the cctv
network
whoa yeah was that tracking him now and
i've issued a warrant for his arrest
she needs your help i need your help
we're here for you
oh
you want me come get me
i got you
[Music]
hello hi this is marlo yes
harper yes
come in
the words i have to say it's a beautiful
house
will it just be you staying or
excuse me mrs muller no
until you give your love
there's nothing more that we can do
happen from the garden
yeah it was delicious no no
mustn't do that
forbidden fruit oh god sorry i i'm
drinking
oh
you're tormented
it feels more like
wanted
yeah something happened
my husband
went upstairs to our balcony
and let himself go
you must wonder why you drove him to it
why i didn't drive him to him
i could be true
but if you'd given him the chance to
apologize
he'd still be alive
what
a man
followed me out of the woods
he was stalking me what makes you say
that i saw him twice
twice i don't know if he saw you once
[Music]
i'll play a game
you hide
i'll see
you must feel an awful sense of
guilt
stay away from me
[Music]
[Music]
whisper
i am person boot
holy freakolos
you lunch me
[Music]
and the rest of you play double time
hey giant
hey you want to see something cool
you've been great get home safely good
night
you're still here
okay okay one more number i call this
one the legend will never
[Music]
i have bad news you died
[Music]
doctor
relax i am [ __ ] booze i have night life
and how many times have you died already
uh
i am not really a mad guy
hola florida do you like aspartame
does this have shellfish in it
a cat always lands on his feet what
[Music]
and then there was the giant today so
what is that like uh
a four
that makes eight puss what do you wish
to do with your last life when you only
have one life
that's what makes it special
fear me if you dare
goldilocks and the three bears crying
family
you're supposed to be dead
it never fails whenever i team up with
you things go wrong trust me
you gotta trust him look at those eyes
you killed that cute no
and with the paws it's all so
cute
am i doing it stop you're gonna give
yourself a hearing
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snow my god oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
welcome
to the new norm
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here let's turn up the
oh heat the winter soldier
fear not citizens you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
we stick together
no matter what
you forgot one
[Music]
and die unstoppable a guy named knuckles
you are really bad at punching
what's the worry here nick you've lost
some of your talent as an actor
no
what did he say he says he loves you but
he went in a different direction
i'm done i'm quitting acting tell the
trades it was a tremendous
honor to be a part of storytelling and
myth-making
[ __ ] man i'm driving through the hills
i'm sorry one more time
we got another offer it's a million
bucks it's to attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party i would never
do that it's the easiest gig ever you
play yourself what do we know about this
guy anyway is he into something strange
it's not like he's gonna want you to
suck his dick or [ __ ] his wife or watch
you watch him [ __ ] his wife i wouldn't
think so
welcome to mallorca mr cage the guy that
owns this house what's his name cubby is
hobby gonna want me to uh
play him cubby
nick cage
god this place is stunning what is your
favorite movie that's one of those
questions that's impossible to answer
you can't just limit it to one imagine
me and you i do
is it too much
is this supposed to be me
it's protest
i'll give you twenty thousand
[Music]
four we could have died
i'm in position i think that's the actor
nick cage nick h i love you
have you seen poster i'm 44 years old
why the [ __ ] would i see croods too i've
seen face-off and con air
you guys want we're with central
intelligence do you know who you're
spending time with one of the most
ruthless men on the face of this planet
i need you to help the us government
[Music]
find a way into that room nick
i can see myself doing more of this
stuff i think i might have a real gift
for it good because we got another
mission for you no no no no no
your friend is working for the u.s
government don't lie to me
are those my golden guns they're my
golden guns i don't want to kill you
you're the last person i want to kill i
love you i love you
whoa cage
[Music]
we all have to die what's important is
what you do before you go
[Music]
i'm the bad man i have been for a long
time that's three people likely killed
with the same weapon what's that round
them on the floor you'll shoot us losing
his mind
anything else i can do for you the room
number again it's on the key order ah
the retainer for your services is 10
million dollars
no
call the contractor i don't hurt
children ever
listen to me very carefully the girl
stays alive you're answerable to me
a 13 year old been relocated to a group
home shot here last night
yes what's wrong you're sure
hugo thinks it's a pro settling scores
trafficking vince and sierra i can't
keep doing your job for you who is this
you're too slow to make the bay what
they did to children they're not doing
anything about it
he's taking out the traffickers that we
couldn't
he's interfering with an international
investigation
you said he wasn't going to be a problem
i've done crazy things
why don't you and i just have a talk i
know you're not well no time for that
if i'm dead you'll never know the truth
stand down
i want to believe that you're a good man
vincent
if i can't finish this you have to
but they have to be punished
which side of this do you really want to
be on
i want justice
we all have to die what's important is
what you do before you go
i have like you
heard the tall tales told about the
marsh girl
an abandoned child
i had a family once
they called me kyle
[Music]
a little girl surviving in the marsh on
her own
reviled
and shunned
hello miss kyle i hear y'all by muscles
[Music]
sometimes i feel so invisible
[Music]
i wonder if i'm here at all
you are
[Music]
i think you're gorgeous i want to get to
know you better
[Music]
there's no fingerprints on the railing
great stuff
no fingerprints
being isolated was one thing
being hunted
quite another you didn't see
me here a marsh girl she killed him i
know you have a world of reasons to hate
these people i never hated them they
hated me they harassed me
you want me to pick from my life
i won't they're not deciding anything
about me
[Music]
in spite of everything trying to stomp
it out
life persists
[Music]
every creature does what it must to
survive
how many fires you see we
[Music]
i reckon 11 or 12.
[Music]
i'd be damned i ain't seen no negro 12
flags
so i gotta stick in their graves though
i guess everybody got to prove
themselves we've been in change by your
kind for years
so he's a slave thing
you see chains on me
or mats around here barking orders
i ain't been no slaves since i ran out
that plantation
what was all that about we helped him
run the railroad will
he slays up north of freedom's land
boy get out
these words is my world
the truth is just waiting to be found
god damn it we found it we're gonna hurt
you downstairs
[Music]
[Music]
you